Hello Freak bitches.
In the heterosexual world,
what percentage of strip clubs in the United States are for men?
Well,
there's a lot more,
I'm sure
there's like one Chippendales in the county.
You got to do some research and if they're only open on,
you know,
you gotta make your reservations and shit the fucking like,
it's a different experience.
Like when girls go to see men strip,
they scream,
they scream and they throw money in the air and they look crazy and they'll rub
their face on the dude's dicks.
Like girls at Bachelorette parties,
they go fucking,
why is it because they don't go as much.
Like as often,
you know,
agreement.
They could go off on bachelor parties and they're not.
Yeah,
they're not going to say shit.
It's like what happens at the Bachelorette party stays there.
Right.
I had a dear friend of mine who I used to do taekwondo with,
that was a male stripper.
Two Friends of mine actually.
One was his young Puerto Rican kid and the other one,
this is older white dude and the older bite to it was a really nice guy.
Very smart guy.
But he was like over the top.
Strange Big Jack.
Was He shredded though?
Jack Black Belt.
Black Belt martial artist.
He was a big Jack Dude,
you know,
but he was telling me,
he was like,
these women,
they go fucking crazy.
Like it gets really scratching calm and shit.
Just sucking tech
friends.
The girls who were getting married,
we just suck his dick in front of their friends.
But to the guys,
a strip club to dudes by himself in the quarter,
all quite as fluff fucking
strip clubs when it was dead as fuck.
I worked those Saturday day shifts that shitty.
You open up on 11 and there's one girl and no dude's and realize wait
[inaudible] the security cameras the see.
And then one guy walks in but only sit there and he's just,
it's Saturday and one 15
girl.
She's fucking rag in
Shitty Shit.
And I'm sitting there playing Depeche mode and shit.
It was dark friends like,
dude,
you're so lucky you
just orgies going on.
And I'm like Dj and like eating pussy
French like,
dude,
give me a job.
I'll just pick up cokes and shit.
Man,
you're so lucky.
I'm like,
ah.
But then ended up moving up and getting good shifts.
You just wait for the DJ and yeah,
when you first get in,
you got the worst shifts.
Saturday day,
Monday day,
Saturday day one,
Jay darkness.
That's really funny.
You know,
I had them ever reminds me,
I used to have a pretty serious hard drug problem to which a hard drugs,
which I,
I done,
you know which ones heroin and crack and oh damn.
Gotten through it.
And the needle or the smart starting smoking,
smoking,
no needles,
no needles.
Stayed away from that,
but you know,
made it through and I'm damn him.
How'd you get on that?
How to get on him.
Um,
oh,
pain.
You had some injuries or something.
No pain.
Emotional pain,
muscle pain,
emotional suffering,
pain,
last,
aimless,
wandering the world.
Aimless,
not knowing what to do.
And that was the escape was the heroine.
Somebody introduced me to it about that period in time and it just was like,
oh wow.
You know,
heroin has the great ability of,
um,
and it's really seductive and really fucked up of making you think that your
life is okay when you're in the gutter.
Wow.
It has that sort of,
that shooting that it just kind of bubble it puts over you.
You can be literally living in an alleyway high on heroin thinking you've got it
going on.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's really weird and perverse like that.
And at that time in my life,
I mean my dad just died.
Um,
and you know,
when he died,
what with it,
what went with it was kind of my life up until I was 22 up until that point.
Like my life was in that bubble,
you know,
he was larger than life.
He was famous,
you know,
girls came with that work,
came with that,
a scene came with that.
Friends came with that and when he died that just,
I went,
poof,
girls want to bang you because you were,
oh,
of course.
Delivery son course.
Yeah.
Really Nice.
It worked out for awhile.
Did you put on like a guru attitude?
Like,
Oh God,
it lacks,
I've got it all going on ladies at that time,
that,
that stage in my life now,
I was a disaster
and I tried to do that now though in the kitchen.
Oh,
but no,
I had a good story minutes.
It was really funny and like you were talking about soliciting the government
for money,
for being an acid casualties,
which is a good idea.
But I was really high and crack once,
um,
and just kind of on a bender,
just losing my mind and crack and I thought in the middle of the night and be a
really good idea to join the CIA and that they would want me,
me specifically being like Tim Leary's Kit,
they'd want me because I have access to shit that they want access to.
Right.
Like I can be an inside.
I was a mall and it was high on crack and I downloaded,
I filled out the form.
I got that deep.
I spent hours on it.
It's really long.
Complicated though.
The whole kindest joined the CIA,
printed out,
sent it in the mail,
sense it in the mail,
in your mouth.
You're in the CIA there with Anderson Cooper.
He worked for CNN.
Well yeah,
you're in there and never heard back.
But it was never heard back.
Maybe never seen laughing,
laughed and threw it in the garbage,
I'm sure.
But it was really funny and kind of a great delusional high on drugs,
man.
Wow.
So what did you think that you were going to do?
What?
Like as nomad a operative.
Are we going to do,
we gotta fix it from the inside with crack?
Yeah,
something like that.
Wow.
Something crazy.
You know,
like you can't fuck them,
but you could kill him.
Yeah,
you can eat them,
but you can't fuck them.
Yeah.
So you can't do a dual purpose.
You can't kill him.
Fuck him.
Then eat them because then you're fucking a dead animal.
And that's gross.
Illegal.
I think it's more legal to fuck a dead animal than a live animal.
Does that make sense?
Because what are you doing?
And then you're really just masturbating cause there's not a living thing in
your presence.
It can't be raped
debt.
But you notice how there's like stages of like how you feel about the dead
animal.
There's like one stage one is the live animal,
right?
If you fucking alive animal you crazy asshole,
what are you subject to that animal to sage to your fucking a dead animal.
Like what is wrong with you?
Like why?
Why do you want to fuck this thing?
Forget about whether you should be able to do it,
but if you kill it and then eat it right,
everybody's fine with that because that's like what you're supposed to do but
you can't fuck it's body.
But what if you just jerked off with a chicken cutlet?
What if you took a chicken,
he wrapped around your Dick and someone came in the room and like,
what the fuck you doing Greg?
Like,
dude,
I'm telling you,
it sounds crazy but it feels so good and I just cleaned it up and then I eat it
for dinner.
It takes a bite.
What's this nice cream sauce?
How dare you,
now that you say fucking a chicken cutlet,
it's all I can think about it because he had slippery Bree.
It's soft.
When those GMO chickens,
it would wrap right around your heart.
Hell yeah.
And it's a breast.
You thinking about it being at your tit fuck in it.
You know what you would do?
You would take a bag like a,
what?
I'm Ziploc storage bags.
You get the chicken cutlet in the bag and then heat up some water to about a 99
degrees and then you dunk the chicken cutlet in the water so that it heats up.
It gets,
but you know like a body skin temperature.
Yeah.
Then you just covered that bitch with k y yeah.
Just lather it in there.
And then you put an oven Mitt on
the cutlet.
You wrapped that Cutler around your shaft.
Oh,
crimes against humanity.
Never felt so good.
And then yeah,
you can eat it,
eat it.
You're gonna Cook that Shit because you've tenderized it.
Especially like you don't have to use in edible oil.
You could jerk off with a nice avocado oil or coconut oil.
You,
you know,
avocado oil has a high flashpoints oil to jerk off with.
Yes.
Cause then after you're done,
as long as you don't come on your chicken,
oh,
you know,
you pull out,
that's gross.
We don't want to come on your food.
But that way we'll be like really green.
Yeah.
Multiple uses.
I love it.
[inaudible]
yeah.